[Music]
has uh has anyone been linting
they've been linting really hard no i
told you i'm no quitter
yeah did you survive your first mardi
gras taco are you doing any of the
linting uh nope i haven't given up
anything
okay
in fact i have to go twice as hard now
because of all the people giving up you
know like beer yeah now i've got to
drink more beers so yeah counting on you
it's a hard life people what are the
things what other things are you doing
to
to make up for other people's
lent uh that's about it just just okay
is there anything else anything else i
should uh i should tune into and pick up
any should i start smoking
you could do that yeah try smoking for a
little while should i vape
yeah i uh
mardi gras is great uh but i will say
after 10 14 days this
i've never wanted to lent so hard in my
life and i'm not catholic
i'm not religious at all there's a
reason these things were created and
continue right now i understand the
purpose of being
full of lent or being lentiful what is
the word i don't even know how to
talk about this am i linting have i
linted i don't know that len lent's a
verb until you until you made it one but
it works i'm going hard i'm going hard
after lent going hard after lent uh i
have uh successfully successfully guys i
have gone a whole day so far without
drinking
this is big
i just i just started delivering
yesterday you see your hands
okay
okay
i just started the lint yesterday
uh now granted i'm about three days late
four days late but i started yes i feel
great
as long as you get there
yeah
yeah but i know why they're doing it now
barry now i understand
uh your people i understand why you guys
need this so bad because it beat me the
hell up i bet
i bet how long is the landing gonna last
you're gonna go the full 40 i i think
i'll make it to tomorrow about 4 30.
40 hours yeah pretty good
40 hours my people my people span the
desert for 40 hours
good for you yeah
i'm glad you survived it do you see
anything crazy everything crazy it was
so much fun it was the most
it's crazy that um
people especially on mardi gras day
are so emotional
i mean people are crying on mardi gras
day and i think you know partly it's
because of the you know quarantine and
not being able to do this for a little
while but
apparently this is a thing where people
get very emotional on mardi gras day
because of the sheer magnitude and the
beauty of the entire moment
um you know i will say i've been talking
a lot in the past day or so with you
know professional people especially in
the company and they're you know
obviously worried about ukraine and
the humanitarian aspect of everything
that's happening there but here
it's almost as if none of that's
happening
you know it's like we have just went
through the gauntlet of mardi gras and
we're just now waking up and saying
there's a war
what
what happened
um so i do feel a little like out of
touch and out of it um but it was as
fulfilling and as exhilarating of a a
week and a half as as i could have found
i wore a costume
the costume was on my head
that's a lot of alcohol
[Music]
or the right
alcohol didn't throw up the wife threw
up once uh we didn't i didn't i kept
swimming together yeah i kept it
together
well i mean new orleans like we've said
before is the uh you guys
suffer more than most cities
and for to be shut down for two years i
can see where blowing it out was uh
overdue and then uh the best part was
on friday the friday after mardi gras
and the saturday after mardi gras and
the sunday after mardi gras there is
crawfish everywhere
everywhere
i must have had 110 pounds of crawfish
over the weekend it was massive
i couldn't give up crawfish oh why would
i do that yeah okay well i you know
that's the point of lent give up
something you love
well
barry
that's what i'm here to talk to you
that's what i'm here to talk to you
about
are we on a break
we've gone through more breaks than
we've been on
uh so uh today it's a shakiness day so
we've got two artists today that we're
gonna talk to that are appearing at
shakiness
which is
one of those festivals some sort of like
boston calling that if you don't know it
and if you don't go to it on a regular
basis
it probably is just another afterthought
but shakiness is like
to
i think it's my favorite festival in the
south that's not one of the top ones
right it's not it's not the big one but
boy it's so well done it's crafted in
such a
fantastic manner the the lineups are
always
spot on for me and uh you know year
after year
the they move spots they move locations
it just keeps getting better
yeah
really good lineup as we've talked about
i can't wait
yeah if everything falls right i might
have to join you down there for at least
one of those days taco uh yeah you
should i'm sorry you're gonna do what i
think you know which one wait barry you
have to leave the state
yeah i know i believe in my
basement yeah
i don't know i don't know i know i don't
think you're ready for this
it's a big if but if
things fall away i hope yeah
i definitely
that uh that sunday looks really good to
me all right tell me who's on sunday
well my morning jacket krungbin death
cab band of horses coin
i mean that's that sounds like a what
podcast lineup right there
except for all those bands we haven't
talked to
you well you found one and you're like
you know what no
coin oh yeah we didn't have cronkite
that's right yeah i've talked about my
morning jack a lot uh-huh he'll be on
someday one day uh well there was going
to be a time uh in a previous lineup
that we were going to do a cooking show
with my morning jacket and it did not
pan out but i was so excited
when they were in were they on the first
bonaroo lineup that didn't happen in the
second well maybe they're on both either
way they pitched me the idea of doing a
cooking segment with them and i thought
that was so much fun uh so maybe we can
do it again i don't know i don't think
how we cook will we cook you guys want
to boil crawfish
sure yeah
yeah
what else can you do
much maybe a spaghetti
yeah pasta
all right kids you like macaroni and
cheese yeah you open the can you pour it
and you heat it up yeah uh all right
cook that pasta the uh so two bands in
particular it's a shakiness one uh is
gangs of youth now if you do not know
gangs of youth
they are getting a little bit of heat on
radio stations like mine because uh
they've signed a big record deal um
they've
i think they're
tonally they're so interesting i like
their new album
they had a song on my radio station for
a hot minute i felt like i was
maybe the only guy in the country that
was obsessed with this song angel of 8th
avenue
so you know they've definitely got
something i think they're really really
interesting i do not know what their
live show is like but that would be one
that i would circle because i just like
the band i want to give them the pine
grove treatment
one band that i saw at shakines it's one
of these festivals that's perfect for
exactly this
i heard this one song of them and now i
want to see if it translates live right
you know shakiness is the best at
finding those that's how i found
churches for the first time i really
like that one church's song let me go
see him and see if i like it obsessed
right still vanessa was like that for me
at shakinese
went to see pine grove
at shakinese and um that would be the
last time i ever see pine grove
uh
but now you know and but now i know i
love that song that uh
it's it's a
it's a really good song but i just can't
get past the kid wearing shorts on stage
can't get past it i cannot get i can't
get past a dude that's wearing shorts on
stage i see your cell phone in one
pocket your car keys and the next it's
like
are you here or you're not
are you are you going shopping
afterwards are you gonna actually engage
or were you shopping and then somebody
said oh by the way you've got a show in
five yeah we need you to come play
guitar and sing whiny indie rock
um
but i so but that's the perfect
place for a band like that is shakinese
is they can expose themselves to uh you
know
a quality crowd who's really into this
sort of stuff and and gain a you know of
a fan forever i think gangs of new york
is is one of them i'm sorry gangs of
youth is one of them circles
it's it's one gang many youths yeah okay
it's not gangs of youth no no
gang of zeus gang of youths yeah okay
the youths
the youths it's funny you mentioned the
uh the uh costuming because max gets
into that with us which i thought was a
lot of fun
during our conversation so and plus he's
just a fun dude oh he was great
yeah i think we could probably talk to
him about pretty much anything
yeah exactly and i think we sort of did
and i think uh
i think they got to be pretty good on on
stage just just because of the hair
that's a lot of hair i know we i was i
was hoping we'd make it more than 10
minutes before we started talking about
hair
we didn't do it
it's close
so that's the first part second part
is an interview that i did a couple of
weeks ago on the
debut day of spoon's new album with
my best friend in the world brit daniel
so we are best friends uh we
are two peas in the pod we hang out we
chit chat we call each other all the
time my best friend brit daniel
i
love
spoon i love brick daniel i've got the
biggest man crush on britt daniel and um
i don't know if during the conversation
i tried to bring it up the time that we
hung out and you know laverne and
shirley our way through acl but i don't
know if he really remembered it
i think that he did
uh sure that he did he returns your
calls right
oh yeah all the time why would he return
them he's answering them on the first
date he's calling you yeah
nice
so we talk about the new album which by
the way
um if you haven't heard lucifer on the
sofa
i
can't stop listening to this and i don't
want to get premature
and have recency bias because lord knows
there's nothing i hate in this world one
of the reasons you buy us but um
oh this new spoon album might be my
favorite spoon album of all time
it is incredible
good there you go you haven't listened
one second of it
oh my god
i'm gonna i'm i'm i'm just sitting here
and i'm sure russ is thinking the same
brad has a lot of best friends doesn't
it friends
everybody's
[Laughter]
it's i've got brit brittany and brad
that's it
yeah oh the circle is widened then yeah
you know i've always said brad only
likes two people himself and the other
is fluid so fluid
no fluid meaning it's it's not it's not
a liquid you're not saying i love fluid
no it could be it could change got it
okay there's always it's one plus one
b plus one yeah whoever my plus one is
for the day sure yeah um so those are
your two those are your two shaky knees
uh artists for today
we've had coin on so you can knock them
off the list gangs of youth no gang of
youth
okay
and spoons
very excited for both
fans today
we okay we've had krung ban
kung's bins yeah
grung green bin
in there
i'm getting there i like it uh yeah so
there you go that's what you get today
and then um is there anything else we
need to get to uh do we want to talk
about the the bonnaroo stuff you wanted
to go yeah let's say that let's let's do
that uh once we get through these two
um let's talk to max from gang of youths
now on the what podcast
[Music]
now we're finally here in dublin so it's
really exciting but yeah literally just
sound checking well congratulations
oh thanks man where are you bro
i'm in new orleans right now barry is in
uh tennessee
and russ is right outside of tennessee
in northern georgia north georgia um
holy [ __ ] that's that's such a cool uh
group of places i i mean is it
yes
are you joking like well i'm just making
sure like how how many trips have you
made uh to the states in the last year
or so since uh everything really sort of
blowing up
well dude like i um i have a huge love
for the south man and i know that that
not all of the places just listed are
like
hard out the south but
um i love all that wilderness stuff man
like i used to i did a summer working in
the shenandoah valley
which is way up further on and the
appalachians up on in western virginia
and um i've just so whenever i'm in
those sorts of places where there's like
all the trees and the fireflies and the
vibe
i want to get i want to get down to like
new orleans though and check out all the
swamps oh please do let's wrestle some
gators
let's wrestle some games dude
i uh my brother would be useful with
that um he he used to live in darwin
which is literally where crocodile
dundee is set
um
and uh he's always uh in the middle of
the wilderness with his bow and arrow
um but i'm kind of like i'm the sort of
the city slicker the latte supper of the
family the latte super um what were you
doing
what were you doing in the shenandoah
valley what now was that about
i did i just did like a lot of um kiwi
i'm in new zealand the um mostly
actually not anymore two of the band
ozzy
the front man dave is aussie
um but salmon um
and then tom's english and john's from
chicago
um but yeah we
a lot of kiwis when they're like 19 18
19 go and work in the states and summer
camps just a way to get a visa and then
go traveling
so i did that bro it was awesome okay uh
everyone thought i like knew how to
start fires and [ __ ] because i'm from
new zealand but i don't really know what
i was doing
um i i kind of had like
i had like more mana than i deserved um
for sure
um but it was fun
what is it so you guys
you go no it's it is remarkable like the
the way that we look at uh as americans
we look at other people especially just
like cavemen that's all you are to us
it's cavemen you can start fire with
your hands and
yeah you can uh out a you know a large
animal with a boomerang or something
in the case of my brother that's like a
weirdly accurate stereotype
uh but uh but not me so much um but now
we love the outdoors the whole band like
there's something about united states
man that it's just so super underrated
people don't um
like if i lived in the states bro i
would have a car for one i live in i
live in london that makes no sense
um but i would have a car
and uh i would just boost
all the time to like waterfalls rivers
you know
mountains it's just great bro but um
yeah anyway i'm sure you don't want to
talk about that no i do i do i'm
actually all into it yeah
it raised it raised another question
what is the perception
what do you think the perception people
have
of
your music based on where you're from
oh man um
i don't i think it differs to where you
are like
i feel like in the united states
australians and new zealanders are
a little bit random like we're so small
that i don't know if there is much
preconceived ideas about it apart from
like big acts like tame impala or
um
you know recently um and
people like lord and stuff like you know
there's some big sort of antibiotic acts
but
a lot i don't know if there is much but
i think in england like there's a lot of
aussies and kiwis and we're really
annoying and like we over drink and like
we live together in like massive flats
and [ __ ] like
uh so i i think it's like almost works
against us
in england
and uh
yeah i did you're no you do not want to
be a london aussie trust me i know we
love we love we are london aussies so we
can't talk um but yeah no like so i
think yeah whereas in the states i think
there's a lot more like like we're just
sort of seen as like being oh that's
kind of interesting you're from you know
the other side of the world but i don't
i never feel judged or anything
by americans tonight can i stop real
quick
just what is a kiwi
a kiwi is um is a um
uh a
bird
a flightless bird
uh that is the national emblem
uh of new zealand okay just why the word
which is when you say when you buy kiwi
from whole foods like the fruit
it's called a kiwi because it's from new
zealand
but okay that's the name is derived from
a bird so to be like calling like
uh the canadians if you call them like
hockey punches yeah yeah or like a
moulton or like yeah or called you guys
i i could say
dodgy stuff about what you call
america's pbr
um
yeah pickup truck and oh you know the
i don't know what sister it's like don't
offend anyone let's get to the the real
question that i have how in the world do
you guys have the best set of hair of
any band that's on the planet right now
you guys all have great hair uh which is
just a it's a it's it's it's l'oreal
paris dude no it's not um no it's um
it's uh we just i don't know dave's
wife's a hair stylist and she does all
our hair my wife actually just cut my
hair though
so she killed me if i mentioned that um
but uh no i don't know what it is man
you just when you're in a band you're
allowed to belong here even though
you're uh
probably too old to have long hair so we
uh well this is a big it's a big part of
our show which is why brad yeah we try
to spend five to ten minutes on hair
yeah you know it's hair is important to
us so yeah
that's that's great man
that's pretty much all we got for you uh
so oh fantastic i have a good night
so so about the band now i became a fan
of you guys because you know i work in
radio and we get service singles and i
had never really heard of you guys and
the minute that i heard the first single
off of the new album i was like man this
is this has got so much like national in
it um and i love the national so that
that was the first you know four yeah
tell me about the band tell me about
where you guys came from how you found
each other and and
you know before up until the new album
uh how it all came to be
it's interesting to say the national man
because one of our best mates is a guy
called peticatus who made
who produced boxer and um alligator and
high violet
um
but uh and he produced one song on this
record and he mixed a couple on this
album the new one um
and so we obviously have that connection
of like a mutual friend um
but i do think a lot of the time because
dave matt berninger kind of
broke ground on that like
you know i mean obviously leonard cohen
as well but like in terms of like an
indie rock band having a singer with a
low voice yeah so i think sometimes dave
um
like even no matter what he does you
would get that comparison sure because
he has that range
but i think i think there's like yeah
anyone like dude like box is probably
the most one of the most foundational
albums to our age group
if you loved indie rock music
so like i don't think you can be a you i
don't think you can be honest and not
sort of
tip your hat to the national like we
[ __ ] love the national um
but yeah like i think on this record
especially like the influences are a lot
more random than that
and um
you know it's sort of more you know new
american
minimalism and like full of glassy steep
rocky instrumentation and uk garage like
break beats
um heavily using samples from the
pacific islands like i think this record
is like
a departure from that but a lot of our
older stuff and until an extent i guess
like angel of 8th avenue which i think
was the first single
still has that feel of like the driven
drums um
and but it's yeah it's hopefully lean
and
gliding um
you know in a way that yeah i guess the
national can do really well but is that
but is that the is that the sound that
you guys started as when when you guys
first
i think like we've never really had the
balls to like
attempt what we did on this record um
and it's something we've always loved
and sort of hope to do like we've always
been very string heavy dave's an amazing
arranging strings and now we have tom
hobden who uh joined the band who used
to be and mumps and sons but before that
no on the whale
um so he
he kind of has that
he's like a genius uh string arranger so
he's taking us to the next level with
that you're hearing a full orchestra on
on the record uh he went to budapest and
recorded with a full section
go ahead i'm sorry
no you're right no no please i was one
of the things that uh tyrone we talked
to tyrone from rufus this old a couple
weeks ago and one of the things he said
was there was national radio
uh in australia and what an influence it
was because you got to hear so many
different things because i think the
question i think brad you would ask is
you know where do you get these
influences and
you know coming from australia and he
said being able to hear all these
different influences
was um i don't i'm not put i don't mean
to put words but freeing or liberating
or whatever you know it was you could do
whatever you wanted to do
kind of thing did did you have that did
you guys have that as well
i i think like um dave who's like the
leader of the band really um
and uh you know
this is his story about his dad that he
wrote you know and
i think for him he's
like he was raised by the internet
and uh television
uh in a lot of ways he's like one of the
most intelligent people
i've ever met
uh who knows everything it's like a
walking wikipedia page um you know
sometimes
uh a wikipedia search engine i mean like
he just knows everything and i i so i
feel like he kind of grew up
loving classical music and
uh
listening to a huge array of things you
know going down to the public library
listening to stuff um i think the rest
of us have our own stories with it like
i
i was probably more just like a small
town kiwi kid who listened to whatever i
could and my big brother kind of would
like give me a record every now and then
like rage against machine or something
and i would get into it or whatever but
i um
yeah i think we just all
uh constantly tom's literally a
classically trained you know went to the
royal college of of london to learn
violin so it's like he comes from that
world
so it's sort of this desperate donny was
like a jazz drummer
you know so it's like this well these
are these are all so many influences
yeah this is so many different uh
experiences how in the world did you all
find each other
we we all met at um so a couple of them
so
four of the original members of whom um
sorry like
like dave myself and um jung were
originally like start of the band uh
with two other guys that um basically
four of them went to uh church youth
group together so they met through that
and i went to high school with dave
um so i met him there
and then so we kind of started in this
shared experience um in a in a large
evangelical church movement me less so
me um
but that's kind of how the boys made it
up and
um that's really cool in some ways
you're allowed to play music and you're
allowed to be really crap at it you know
um regularly like i'm sure a lot of
american listeners can especially in the
south can relate to that like um i mean
i went i was my dad was a small town
pastor in a small
uh
city in new zealand so i i grew up
playing different instruments and stuff
every single week you know from when i
was about 11 with no choice i had to you
know i mean someone yeah you really do
get a very long you get a very long
leash when you uh yeah
he just sounds so good sitting behind
that drums
blessing yeah yeah and it's
you're allowed to but like you know what
it teaches you man like even if you suck
at your instrument which most people who
play in those places don't they're
actually amazing but even if you do suck
you're learning uh how to play in a band
like how to play with people whereas i
think a lot of other people like they
don't get that till high school um
where they get a chance to like
routinely play like you know which we
all did as well you know we all were all
playing like it smells like teen spirit
on repeat or whatever
um
in high school but i i think yeah so we
all met like that and um
but it was very early on that we became
a band like i met the other guys really
at the first rehearsal
and we were just like
we kind of had shared experiences but we
all loved music and we were very random
like we're very not we're not a very
easy fan to brand because we don't
wear the same [ __ ] we're not all like
70s long-haired
i kind of look like that but i'm kind of
like a dorky new zealander dad
um and then like you know dave's a
samoan man who grew up in like
uh like in a western inner city suburb
of sydney jung's from chicago
he's he's korean descent you know donnie
grew up in another city so it's like
it's kind of like we don't look like a
band
and then we were on stage like we were
dressed different which we're trying to
get better at
that like so we've been doing this like
a decade but we kind of have this um we
probably look like a group we're best
friends in the whole world we've lived
together for long periods of our lives
we literally just went on a holiday with
all of our wives
uh you know like we hang out off the
clock
but we don't look like we look like we
met at like a like a social club and we
all come from different places like we
don't have like a
afraid of like a scene that we came from
if that makes sense yeah
uh
which might be which might be a strength
when it comes to instrumentation because
it it's not locked into one way of
thinking
well look i mean i do think that there
is going to be a resurgence of
um
getting back to the basics at some point
you know uh yeah tick tock has its
moments and yeah it's really easy for
you to get a um
a career out of a youtube page at this
point but there is still something that
drives us to especially hardcore music
fans drives us to the struggle to the
guys that just feel like our buddies um
and
you know there's there's that thing
feels like it's gonna come back at some
point um i would i would suggest
coordinating outfits though uh it does
drive me a little nuts when a band is
not paying any attention to what they're
wearing it means
we
we we think about them now man like i'm
good
we're like we're like you know
we've got like teams around us now that
you know harass us about this [ __ ] um
but
i what i mean is it's not um as long as
you're not wearing top hats and shorts
you're gonna be okay
brad's biggest pet peeve is somebody
taking their shirt off so as long as
says how long he's not taking his shirt
off you're gonna be okay i reckon i
reckon drummers can bro i'm gonna
disagree with you i reckon drummers can
but uh anyone else who does is a tool i
agree i i understand i understand the
the drummer thing i'm willing to to give
you a taylor hawkins from foo fighters
they're not trying to get attention but
if you're imagine drags if you're dan
who's literally taking your shirt off in
the third song i don't know what you're
doing this for like there's no reason
for you
we can all agree that that's [ __ ]
but yeah that's like
it's like it's just like like you just
need um no no no not directing this to
any person or a musician but like it's
one of those things you just need a good
friend in your life be like bro like
that's not a good look
so one of dude's doing that like uh the
other one was like maroon 5 lead singer
joining us
and just like brother like like you're
way more successful than me and like
full respect to you and your songwriting
but
like put your shirt on bro like i i also
think if you're like
i don't know there's a very small list
of people who pull it off and like
that's right
i definitely yeah he [ __ ] pulls it
off yeah i don't think it might be it i
certainly don't put myself into that
lane
um
yeah well i will say
man i will say the first few episodes
that we uh did of this podcast they were
all shirtless
um
so now that the band has
really found it's it's it's footing and
um you're starting to expand into the
americas
um you have a string of festival dates
one included shaky knees
do you guys
do you guys think of anything
not being american do you have any sort
of opinion about american festivals um
at all american shows in general
i have like a super high opinion of the
man i think american crowds are really
cool
they they they tend to
uh listen to music
that they didn't intend to see which i
think's the yardstick for a cool place
to play at a festival so like
some some countries you play in like if
you're not on their main radio station
like everyone's on their phone when
you're playing you know yeah
um and i feel like americans um it's
obviously way
way way too diverse place to be general
um america um but i think i think on the
whole
uh our experience of playing festivals
there is that people are up for it and
if they haven't seen you before you
actually can win a crowd over it's not
like
um it hasn't been totally ruined by like
tick-tock and stuff yet um
and yeah so i really respect that and um
yeah we're really excited about shaky
knees um i don't know if we're doing any
others that i know of this summer
um because we're doing quite a lot of
headline touring
um but next year we're going to be
trying to 23 we're going to be hopefully
there all the time playing festivals
um
i think yeah what's your name yeah you
go i think that's really cool to hear
you say that about the festivals and
americans because that
to me that's been a shift since bonnaroo
started since the festival thing became
a thing
it's really cool to hear you say
that because i think that's what we've
seen develop
and part of why we do the show is
the the discovery the discovery is part
of the fun
uh that's something that we really
that's why we started the show because
there was a bunch of that's such a cool
that we never heard of and we thought we
need to find out who they are and it
became a game you know and then it
became
i'm not saying we did it but i'm glad to
hear you say that that's really cool
well you you've obviously been part of
that you know you're part of the culture
over there so it's like that's really
cool man i think anything that can
can as a museo that can make i mean i
can think of a really good example where
um the band bahamas which i think is
just staggeringly awesome
um canadian guys um which by the way
barry barry found bahamas on this
show night on a sunday morning at
bonnaroo because i become my favorite
yeah i i i
explained i explained a couple of pics
that i had for barry to listen to before
bonnaroo he got into him and all of a
sudden that's his uh you know get high
and chill out at the house music yeah
clean the house
this is going to infuriate you then
because we played at a festival and i'm
not going to name the country because i
i just don't want to indict
um another place
uh but like it wasn't the states and um
and yeah bahamas was playing and
everybody was just on their phone
because that bahamas i don't think were
on the radio there
and um the funniest thing was like our
whole band
was like lined up
like watching at the very front row and
people coming up and talking to us but
we were just trying to watch bahamas you
know what i mean yeah and yes but it was
just real it was just this realization
like they're so much bigger than us most
markets but in this market it was like a
you know we were a thing at that
festival and i was like it was just like
so confusing to me like
why aren't you watching this band like
you're gonna watch
you might watch us later if you want to
or you'll watch where else later but
like why are you on your phone like why
are you here if you're not here to watch
music um
that was i came home and i was obsessed
it's it's all yeah
for a while
that's so musical man like i really love
uh what they do it's just musical and
like that that's something i'm excited
about for this tour is um i better go
lads um but yeah
but i for this tour like i just think
um you know our other stuff's been a
little bit more direct in terms of the
uh like it's been guitar led or you know
more so and like this this new record i
think is like
way riskier
and harder to play
so much
yeah it may be hard for you to play but
it's so good angel in real time um i'm a
big big fan of it dude i think angel of
eighth avenue is one of my favorite
songs of the year last year uh really if
if you're listening to this give it a
try uh because i really like this band a
lot and i hope when you get over to the
uh the states it's it's as well received
as as i think it will be so all the luck
to you and hopefully we'll see you so
along the way
hey bro yeah come on phone like reach
out or whatever and just get a bear but
um i like uh if you guys you guys do
your thing at the festival i don't know
anyone else in alabama so i might as
well
get a bit but uh but uh not
but um well really nice to talk to you
and um thanks for your uh
you know caring about our band enough to
talk to us
um wherever you guys are in tennessee
and georgia and uh
new orleans louisiana there you go
thanks max thank you see you guys see
you buddy see you guys see you around
[Music]
they might be your discovery this year
what day are they on barry gang of
youths they are on the saturday okay
nine inch nails headliners with churches
not today
not the day you want to go
that's a good one i i mean i like the
whole lineup but yeah i'm not gonna even
pretend and lie to you and say i'm going
all three days i do feel like it's one
of the stronger lineups and for a
festival it's only 25k or so um i think
it is as strong of a lineup as is out
there the entire year yeah you could go
eat any of those three days and be happy
all night what's friday again remember
friday is green day and billy idol
rainbow kitten uh spoon your guy spoons
spoons yeah
we'll talk we'll talk to spoons here uh
soon enough uh brick daniel is my best
friend me and my best friend britt gonna
catch up talk about the new album
lucifer on the sofa here in a second but
what was the uh bonnaroo news this week
that i missed okay because i'd be honest
with you i've not paid attention to
anything yeah go ahead taco
they've made some improvements on the
farm
uh number one storm water management
planning and drainage improvements
i know you guys love drainage
i always like to see that way up high on
the poster but yeah first billing yeah
uh but if if they don't have the sewage
improvements uh
you'd know it
yeah these are these are all
filed under
uh
only us would be talking about it but
we're glad they did all of them can i
tell you uh
a band that we've had on this program
before came to town and they performed
at a
venue in town that will stay nameless
and
i heard that
it got so uncomfortable it's a packed
house
but unfortunately
because it was the first show back into
real life
something had happened with the sewage
lines and when
everybody would flush
the water was going the opposite
direction
so when you walked into the bathroom you
were having to walk around
rivers of sewage
ooh
so the whole venue smelled like raw
sewage
i don't care who's on stage that's a dad
bad night i don't care who's
yeah paul nice to see you mr mccartney
have a good night
gotta go
we've all been on the farm when things
weren't going well
i try not to talk about it like i said i
worked at a funeral home i don't talk
about that i don't talk about things
i've seen in porta potties on the farm
yeah but you really did get a lot of
girlfriends from that funeral home
it's a chick magnet yes it is
[Laughter]
[Music]
what's the second line of that uh
improvement poster
uh let's see you got relocation of
parking and camping areas to better
prepare for weather events
now this sounds kind of known well you
know that just sounds like fancy words
for moving brad
and i don't run yeah i don't like it
this doesn't sound good to me right now
we can read between the lines on that
yeah
this is just fancy words to say
we don't like where you're camping brad
so we're moving you somewhere else
yeah
yeah we're gonna that's that's an issue
for later
so at what point so explain to me the
parts that they would need to move you
from
and move you too
so that it would
be weather flexible
i don't know but they put a little
picture of a bus on here so i like it
[Laughter]
once again thumbs up for me poster
management yeah
that's all you need yeah
it gives a thumbs up from me
thank a lot
the only thing i can think of is
remember the big storm from what four or
five years ago is they just cleared out
center road
yeah and where that where you went there
and they built a bridge kind of on your
own yeah built the bridge now i
understand there's low levels of the
farm and and you know the the storm that
rolled through ida last year that killed
the festival i understand that
there was a reason the grounds were
that's probably
probably hit it
i know that but where are they moving
them to it's i mean they don't have
endless space
yeah i don't know probably higher i
don't know i would assume they paid
attention to
higher ground and that sort of thing
were were you just about to say they
moved to hell i was good
but i let it go
it probably did move some hills but not
the hill
brad always wins in the end brad always
wins in the up this one
alright go ahead there's three or four
more
they've paved roads there's additions of
pave roads across the farm
paving roads
would you be okay if they paved
the main roads inside cenaru that's what
i think they did no
and at first i thought no i don't like
that um
i don't think unless you remember that
big puddle that forms there
leaving vip going into cinnaroo
be cool if that was not there anymore
i know i know that but
i just have roads across festival
grounds it doesn't specifically say
center room now i could see if they
paved the main drags around camp right
and but i just don't know if i would be
okay with them paving roads inside
cinero why
something would feel almost you'd miss
the dust and the puddles you know it's
not just the dust or the puddles it just
feels
i don't less connected to the earth
maybe i i had the same thought over the
weekend but then i kept thinking about
those puddles that you gotta walk you
know when you go through those wooden
gates
stepping over and around
there's no fun in that i understand i
don't know why i don't haven't
i haven't really put a finger on why
this would bother me but it would make
me feel a little yeah a little bougie a
little like uh i feel like i'm at a city
festival all of a sudden i think the
point of being a bonnaroo is that you
get these rough around the edges things
i don't i don't know if i'd love a uh
i'm okay with a flushing toilet okay let
me make that clear i'm okay you're not
you're not a rough around the edges guy
i know that but this makes me feel like
i am
oh this is it okay they got gravel roads
and everything
yeah
maybe we need to do a little recon and
go down to manchester and see exactly
what they think that's exactly what we
need do you think they've already done
them or they're just saying that they're
going to do them
uh it makes it sound like it's been done
why are you going to talk him out of it
wait a second we have kyle lives in
manchester
oh yeah we can get him over there why
don't we just get kyle drive over there
and see if you can uh see any paved
roads
yeah take video
yeah
i don't know man the last place they
need paved roads is incineroar they
already drive too many carts through
there to begin with um the the the
bumpiness and that actually slows them
down they need to take the service roads
behind because the carts drive me nuts
driving through there that's like that
was sort of part of the plan that was
announced two years ago when it didn't
happen that they had come up with ways
to move the carts around the perimeter
man i hope so i do too that's the most
because man i tell you that the best
part of lollapalooza is how they have
organized
sort of their transportation in and
around that festival uh the carts
driving through
bonnaroo don't make any sense and they
just get in the way yeah coming up on
you all the time yeah and also and also
paving roads would mean that they're you
know planning to continue
driving through cenaru when it's much
more important to get paved roads out
around uh the premises don't you think
yeah maybe yeah it's part of the uh
wastewater management
rainwater and all that
all right what else we got on a poster
new wayfinding system to better help you
navigate the farm day and night
okay that that's just a sign that's just
a sign
yeah that's it
this way
and then finally even faster entry to
campgrounds due to tow booth and parking
efficiencies yeah this look i just made
it better there
oh there it is
i did it
now i can find my way man i just spent a
lot of money on that new sign
send an email
but
yeah there's
it's a sign right we're we're talking
about a sign we're talking about uh
there could be something on your phone
okay
what else could it be i mean yeah
probably
you know i don't know that's for those
people who have to camp way way way out
do they still own
scorcho
no
let's go
they rented it then they didn't own it
no they didn't own it okay because if
they owned it it would be kind of cool
to take the scorch
and drive it around with like
announcements on
the big screen and you get to see what's
going on and you know do karaoke into it
you know you could put it to use it
would work all right now that would be a
pretty good you know
sign you know that would be a pretty
good investment they bought the scorch
and they they've turned it into yeah you
know it's own character no i'll tell you
that would be a great rehab
to it's it's reputation everybody hates
the scorch el scorcho is back and all of
a sudden it's its own character driving
around making everybody happy
i agree maybe you could wear a scorcho
costume
a mini squirch mini squirt
hey
mardi gras is 345 days away
gotta have it gotta start working on
that interesting yeah
yeah so that's it those are the big ones
and yes they're going to let people in
on tuesday
uh
yeah
and the sooner you get there the closer
you are camped to center room
first is pretty big yeah
yeah that would that i always wondered
about that people who
you know bust their ass to get there
early and then get the worst parking
that sounds like that sounds like the
lead that sounds like the biggest piece
of information here that the sooner you
get there the closer you get to be yep
because weren't we saying a couple years
ago that you know you could get there on
a tuesday but you're still you know yeah
first yeah they start from back
you know towards the middle well that's
not new they've been announcing this for
two years yeah there's just been no
bonnaroo to show for it actually do it
so that's it
they should just keep announcing stuff
just
who cares
you know
50 50 if this map happens certain
announcements stuff
hey the rolling stones are headlining
yeah yeah all right look good uh that's
uh that's all right i mean i think a lot
of that's uh
some good pr work finally
but i don't know if uh much of that is
is meat it feels like the meatier part
is is you get to camp as close to center
as you can the easier or sooner you get
there yeah yeah i think russ and i were
talking before you got on any any of
these improvements are the kind of
things that you know don't normally make
the headlines but
as we've all said over the years the
little things they add up
that's right flushable toilets that's
right that's right and and the grounds
have definitely gotten better and they
look so much better and i will to your
point barry i think that the reason why
we don't hear about them they announce
them plenty but we don't hear about them
because
there's other stuff about it that we're
talking about you know there's so many
other things that were but because we're
in this
you know
barren desert of information about you
know what bonnaroo is going to be we
haven't done it and how long
now it feels like every teeny tiny scrap
of information feels like a feast any
news is news yeah for sure
for sure uh so
the other uh shakinese artist that we
wanted to talk to today was an interview
i did with brett daniel
my best friend
a couple weeks ago when the new album
came out if you haven't listened to it
yet by the way when we were talking to
uh gang of youths you had plenty of time
there barry to listen to lucifer on the
sofa did you listen to any did you get a
couple of tracks no but i promise i will
did you listen to gang of youths before
you talk to them oh yeah
yes i like it very much it took me a
while i kept trying to figure out and i
hate doing this but i'm like everybody
he does everything
everybody tries to taco he always says
i never do this and then he does it
he does exactly this
i hate doing it but it finally dawned on
me they remind me of the call
if you remember the call the song the
walls came down um
yeah okay russ
nothing no i got nothing
jump into that cabin see if you got any
call cds uh reach on in there and see if
you got anything
nothing anyway i like it very much
yeah i like it a lot
uh yeah like i said max was a lot of fun
he was a lot of fun i get a little bit
of national vibes from it so um yep yep
lucifer on the sofa is the new spoon
album uh we talked the day that it came
out so i'm sorry we're just now getting
to this but other things started coming
up like rufus of soul and coin uh but
because i love spoon so much and um
because brett daniel is
best friends best friends yes with me
let's uh spoon on the what podcast
[Music]
what's happening brett hey brad how are
you i'm doing super duper how are you
stranger i'm good the last time you and
i hung out slash talked we were
backstage at acl and i asked you what
you were listening to and you said i've
been getting into the clash these days
and then it wasn't five minutes later
somebody walked up and said hey brett
nice to see you what are you listening
to and you said i'm really getting into
the class these days
that's a
well it's a strong recommendation there
it's hard to go wrong with the clash i i
bet you're still listening to the class
these days i am i am i just admire you
so much i i mean you've got one of my
favorite bands of top three favorite
bands of all time
um and today it's gotta be a really big
day for you so first off congrats i
think you guys put out something damn
near perfect oh wow thank you i have a
face high praise i appreciate that oh
i'm just an idiot on the radio how do i
know um i
want to go back to like when you and jim
since you and jim are still around from
30 years ago did you got what was the
conversation did you envision 30 years
later in 10 albums no we didn't i the
bands that i had been into that i had
been in up until that point all lasted
about nine months to a year and a half
and so that was kind of what i was
picturing uh jim and i were in a band
before spoon that lasted nine months
it's called the alien beats and so
um
it was more it was i think the only
thing that we commented on was like
let's get some better gigs than that
last band had
you know that was it
like let's play not play on monday
nights at the back room this metal bar
and there's a metal bar in east austin
that had an alternative night you know
and that was the gig that was easy to
get but of course no one showed up so
yeah
i remember you telling me though when
you were when this was starting you were
doing something what was your day-to-day
job at the time
right when the band started um
i guess i was just out of college and i
was i was working at a a video game
company oh that's right yes okay not the
one you're thinking of yes i remember
this conversation yeah and what were you
doing there i was i was making sound
effects i wasn't even making music for
them i was just doing
sound effects so like explosion sound
effects and
um
uh
you know a spaceship the door closes you
that kind of sound effect
spaceship takes off that kind of sound
effect
yeah it was a cool job i feel like you
could score a movie if you really wanted
to
i could yeah i mean even even even to
the sound effect part it could go from
the whole gamut from beginning of the
movie to the end yeah it was a good gig
for sure you know it was it was
especially just out of college you know
it was a dream job and they were um when
i was in college we i studied audio but
we didn't
there was no digital audio at that
school so
i got out of school and there's this
video game company says they want to
teach me digital audio and pay me ten
dollars an hour and i just thought i was
you know
it was that would i i don't know i
thought
was this 91 92 yeah 93 yeah that's
pretty good ten dollars an hour 93 is
not bad yeah
um so when uh you guys go through you
know 30 years of this when do you think
that like spoon really found its legs so
when do you think it really got so
because the thing that i feel about this
band that i love so much is that from
the first moment i mean even from you
know telephono to now
it always feels so comfortable in its
own skin
yeah thank you
well
you know a telephono was was definitely
that
the band that was trying to get better
gigs you know that was what that those
songs were all about
and it wasn't really even about making
records and then as as we
of course making record was a cool cool
deal but that's what not what those
songs were written for and then later on
we figured out hey someone's actually
going to put out our records we started
thinking about writing songs in a
different way
um
i think the record
uh maybe 3n called girls can tell is uh
where we
really started
sort of started figuring it out for
ourselves and had some of our own
identity
pop out more what was the song on
girls can tell everything hits it once
you think that was the one or that was a
big one yeah yeah yeah that's the first
song on it and uh
we had definitely never done anything
like that before it had vibraphones it
was very stripped back
yeah yeah i mean i could nerd out about
about your own band um you know pretty
much all day and wax poetic about it but
the thing that i love you know not only
because it's so comfortable in its own
skin but
the re-listen ability if that's a word
is so strong because every time i listen
i don't care if it's a series of sneaks
or whatever you know just and i told you
this before
a random tambourine that walks through
the the room and then you never hear
that tambourine ever again right you
know those kind of a random hand clap
that never comes back again that's the
kind of stuff that i find to be so
interesting that you guys seem to to
find the perfect spots for those things
yeah well that was i would hear that on
a bowie record you know and i'd hear
that on a beatles record
um they were particularly big on
you know really loud percussion elements
like that and i
when we started making records if you'd
work with the producer they'd say yeah
you can put a little tambourine on there
but it's got to be buried in the mix and
you don't want that to stand out and i
said well that's not how the beatles
would do it
um so
there's some arguing about that to start
but uh i'm glad you appreciate that vibe
well i love it uh because it seems as
though it's something that you know if i
was sitting in the room with you that
would be what i would do you know it's
like oh hang on a second we need brett
got it i'm in i'm on the spoon record
you got a nice um nice reverb on those
claps you got going i appreciate that
yeah i've been working on this yeah
so speaking of being in the room with
him the the compliment that a buddy of
mine we were going back and forth about
this new album um
and you could probably say this about
any spoon album
it feels like we're in the room with
them
right is that
there's got to be a purpose for that
there you're actually that's got to be
something that you're actually designing
to do we specifically worked on that for
this record um
and we felt like we wanted to react a
bit against the last one which would the
last one was actually more produced than
than
some of the other ones it was it was
made
um
very much in the studio we're writing
the songs while we're in the studio and
um
figuring out what we were doing with the
songs as we're in the studio this time
we decided well let's let's um
let's hash all that out as a band
playing with each other
uh before we hit the record button you
know sort of an old
maybe a little bit more old-fashioned
way of making a record but there's
something about that you can
even if you don't know anything about
recording or
how records are made i think you can
kind of sense it that this is a band
playing together well what's more
comfortable for you
uh both ways are good i um
you know because i love some some
produced music i do um but
um
i guess
i guess i like the the feel of things
happening happening naturally and things
happening um
sort of like more live
well that's what i was going to do
that's what i was thinking because
the the live show is such a completely
different experience demand that's not
that's not totally true it's not
completely different but it is it is a
much different
feel uh especially when you i'll put it
this way when you said to me at acl you
said well have you seen this show and it
was your latest tour and this was 2018
29 man i can't remember what else he
said you said have you seen this show
and i said no i haven't seen this
specific one but i've seen you guys live
a host of times and you said well this
is the one you need to see
wow listen to that kid well you were
that kid it was three years ago
but but it was it was so specific
because i think that you it had seemed
like you had spent so much time making
that live show
the best one that you guys had brought
to
to the stage i wonder if i wonder if
that sort of like found its way into
this album yeah i think that was a big
part of it you know we we did
we worked on the show you know um and
the way that the show flowed together
and the way that the
um
[Music]
the way that the performance is linked
together in the way that that hit the
audience and uh when we toured more on
that record than we had on any other
record before which is saying a lot for
us and so
we did think like we felt like we were
in a really strong place bandwides and
so it became a thing where let's make a
great rock and roll record that is about
the band less about um
production and more just about how we
play naturally with each other
well i'm not gonna lie to you i mean
that kid was right i mean it was the
best spoon show i had ever seen and i
think there was partly you know there's
you know hometown element there to it
but it still was the best spoon show i'd
ever seen i i wonder if
you feel the pressure the next round of
live shows that when the tour starts in
april is have you have you
you know gotten it up a notch no i know
we we we've done a bunch of shows uh we
played a bunch in september and october
yeah it started it started yesterday
didn't it yeah then we played right um
a show
was it last no the last two two shows
this this week in l.a
and so yeah it's feeling good i
i kind of feel like um
we're we're
we're set up and ready to go it's it's
been they've been some really good shows
well uh bret you're the coolest sob in
rock music i uh
you're you're you might i'm writing that
down
put that on your resume yeah
i uh i really do appreciate you and um i
love spoon with all of my heart and um
i'm so glad you're back i just love this
album so much well i appreciate you
thank you for saying all that and i hope
we get to
uh place i know we're gonna play near
new orleans at some point i hope you get
to some of the show i hope so i will
definitely i'll see you plenty of times
on this tour and um you know
by then i'll have something for you
other than the clash all right yeah come
say hello for sure let's let's chat
again see you buddy
[Music]
all right guys there you go good show
today uh the what podcast uh giving you
bonnaroo tickets one last thing to do
before we get out of here
i could not be happier
with the submission so far for the
bonnaroo photoshop contest
yeah they're pretty great
really really funny you can tell the uh
the artists are listeners that's what
makes it cool
is that what makes it cool or do they
make you look better all right well that
does help i'm much thinner in all of
these graphics
[Laughter]
because they're trying to win and we
have confirmation that it is a baby
some really good stuff so far i i feel
like to me the leader in the clubhouse
is the hand-drawn pictures of
russ berry and brad that to me so far is
my favorite so even you with no artistic
talent
can be a front runner for bonnaroo
tickets all you got to do is uh give us
your best graphic interpretation of the
what podcast whether it be in photoshop
whether or not you drew it on the back
of a napkin
um maybe maybe just maybe you write the
words the what
on a piece of paper and submit it hey
anything that gets uh our attention uh
tag us in it the what underscore podcast
on twitter on instagram uh you can email
us what is the email address again russ
comments at the what podcast got it
any sort of artistic interpretation of
the what podcast will take you know what
i will even say this i'll throw this out
to you guys we could even expand it to
if you wrote us a song
there you go see any sort of artistic
impression
interpretation of the show
and we'll take it there you go what do
you think i'm in uh so
submit those we still have a few weeks
left on that uh so put your uh
creative cap on and submit it today for
bonnaroo tickets and camping pass
anything else gentlemen
i think that's it taco every time we go
to
barry's house it seems as though he's
got more what podcast stickers he's
putting up behind him it's like he's
just finding gear that he hasn't sent
out yet and he's like
as long as i keep pulling i keep pulling
equipment out of trash bins everywhere
and i got to dress them up with these
stickers
i got i got this really cool rack from a
local liquor store they were throwing it
away
so
yeah wow
i know man the wheels alone are worse
was there any liquor in it when you got
it
no not not when it was outside when i
got it home there was licorice
barry what are you doing with the liquor
rack
you should see it i'm proud of it
but what for what what are you gonna do
oh i got all my stuff
i got all my all my got all my stuff
i got a place for my stuff
see i got my treasures
here place for my stuff i got nice
treasures i have a feeling all your
stuff is still everywhere
well
fair enough
fair enough
but it's more organized
would you maybe sell some of that stuff
uh maybe on you know what podcast stuff
yeah that stuff i need to sell
anybody need a koozie
or a t-shirt
i am very worried now all of a sudden
that barry has become a hoarder
you're walking into liquor stores and
stealing furniture
what are you gonna do with that
are you worried about this
i'm not proud
i i want you to see this
i love this thing are you bringing home
pallets too
i'm not gonna answer that
i might have one or
[Laughter]
worried two you
i'm very worried all right there you go
all right good luck no wonder you can't
leave the basement you've got too much
junk i can't get out yes
literally locked yourself into the
basement based on the stuff you brought
home the liquor store is not liquor
confirmed every night yeah love you guys
[Music]
[Music]
consequence podcast network